ma is directed by Tate Taylor and stars
Octavia Spencer as a lonely woman who
begins to invite high-school kids into
her basement to drink and smoke
eventually her basement becomes a secret
neighborhood hangout for all these kids
and one of the coolest places in the
area but as you might expect there's a
lot of darkness in her past and some
horrible things eventually come to the
surface this is the second film this
year I've seen in which a really
well-known and talented actress is
portraying a creeper of sorts on screen
a stalker that just won't go away
the other one was Gretta and similar to
Greta I have a hard time understanding
just exactly why an actress of this
caliber as in a film that isn't as good
as it could be
Octavia Spencer is phenomenal in this
movie you can tell that she is having an
absolute blast she understands the exact
tone this character needs there's some
light-hearted fun to be had there's some
tongue-in-cheek fun to be had and then
there's some horrifying fun to be had
and she is good at every single one of
those beats she's fantastic here and I
relished every scene that she was on
screen she really brings a lot to this
movie and I loved the fact that this
movie exists by far my favorite thing
about this film
setting aside her performance is the
fact that it's actually here in theaters
Octavia Spencer got to play a murdering
psychopath in a horror thriller put out
by bloom house the fact that this movie
even exists is my favorite thing about
it which is still disappointing because
I feel like this movie could have been
great if that script had been given like
three more rewrites because the script
for this movie feels very lazy to me
there are so many moments in which the
characters could stop the film if you
know what I mean there's so many moments
like that throughout the film where
characters have the opportunity to say
or do things that any normal person
would do but they don't take that
opportunity because that would create
sort of a corner for the writer to get
out of
there's many scenes like that throughout
the movie and once you start to notice
them it's like you can't unhear it you
can't unsee it you just begin to see all
these scenes in which characters are
manipulated by the plot con
fines to make the film still happen and
it unfortunately suffers from some
pacing issues as well during the second
act because a plot structure like this
relies heavily on the unknown and once
you begin to know things the film runs
out of steam we have a woman who
obviously has some kind of tortured past
who's inviting kids to her house and
it's strange it's awkward but everyone
kind of likes her for a while
once everyone doesn't like her anymore
the film doesn't really have anywhere to
go but try to get these characters in
awkward scenarios with MA and after a
while that gets kind of boring no matter
how good Octavia Spencer is and I can
totally understand why she would want to
do a role like this because this is
probably really freeing for her and fun
to do a role like this and she's fucking
good at it too I just wish that someone
had given her a better script and Tate
Taylor who also directed the help which
Octavia Spencer got an Oscar for made
this film and on his IMDB he hasn't
really made a horror film before his
last film was the girl on the train
which was more of a thriller a drama and
in the case of this movie there are
times where he has the opportunity to
crank it to 11 and he dials it back they
hint at something that might be really
fucked up and they're like no I'm just
kidding it begins to feel like they were
lazy like they didn't have the guts they
needed to make this movie as fucked up
as it could be even though it is rated R
it's mostly for F words the violence in
the movie is fairly minimal and you can
you can tell that they just they they
didn't quite push it like this could
have been like exploitation extreme
bloody just so in-your-face insanity and
they just settled for okay Allison
Janney shows up in the most thankless
role I've ever seen her in as a
veterinarian who from time to time Peaks
our head into a room and tells Octavia
Spencer to get back to work she's in
this movie this amazing talented actress
to do that but then it dawned on me that
like Octavia Spencer Allison Janney was
also in the help so she probably did it
as a favor for a friend I wish
this movie was better I wish that they
push the boundaries a little bit I wish
that they had the guts to do more fucked
up shit because I really want movies
like this to get made for a couple
reasons one Octavia Spencer and to
paying money for a movie ticket
thus communicating to Studios that hey
we like horror films
with unconventional villains that don't
feel like everything we've seen 1000
times but unfortunately they didn't nail
it
they didn't drive at home this movie
could have been a lot better but still
it's worth seeing for her performance
but I would wait for Netflix or for
Amazon Prime I'm gonna give mah a/c guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]